it's episode 100 if you were to give
your student self a life hack what would
it be have enough and then you wouldn't
have lost your journal of like a decade
oh yeah so I wrote journal a daily
journal for a decade and then one day my
Microsoft Word file corrupted almost all
of the problems in my life can be fixed
by a 10-minute walk a good night's sleep
a glass of water or a wank
seriously this is exactly what I was
gonna say it really rounded a level so
sorry who is the coolest person who
listens to modern wisdom my mum my mum
oh okay some mansplaining man spreading
everything going on in it Manchester
what personality trait has gotten you in
the most trouble trouble
ladies and gentlemen welcome back it's
episode 100 we've done a hundred
episodes of modern wisdom feel like it I
know it's because you've just suddenly
gone twice a week yeah yeah no but
anyway thank you very much to everyone
who tuned in over the last 100 episodes
remember the day we did the first
podcast with you and we had the preamble
of making the coffee and the coffee was
too strong oh that was for propane right
yeah yes how does our interview with you
and then hostages look isn't it crisp it
crisp it it was exactly 16 million
listen minutes later away we are so
we've got a couple of special treats for
you today we're gonna do Q&A we asked
for questions from people on the
internet Instagram have come up with
some pretty good ones also before I
started this podcast as the name that it
was we did here comes the hot potato we
did a pilot episode and originally it
was called Minds mind and matter the
shine a mono mind and mother and we did
a pilot episode on purpose and meaning
as part of that Yusuf told us a story
about when his testicle grew to the size
of a lemon because we've got a hydrocele
and then he tried to pop it in the
shower and then he had a number of other
complications and I've been asked a lot
because I keep referencing it it asks to
put this story in so you're gonna get to
hear it
I've got the footage right now fine
wonderful I'm gonna give you the full
monty this this is a podcast about
purpose and we're gonna spend the first
five minutes
Falls of the moon falls on demand bot
right so one day I was coming out of the
shower
my flatmate saw my ball and said you
said that's really big you need to do
something about it I said no it's fine
it's always been like that was the first
what was the first like the first time
you you're like drying south well when
you looked in the Marriott it's very
gradual and because the male denial of
health issues runs so deep you end up
just ignoring remembering if you want a
doctor I am now I wasn't that so I was I
was even more averse and yeah now I
would be very different I think I would
go after like when I got to half the
size rather before for twice if you're
twice as sensitive to lemon balm not
quite yet exactly my style you know
exactly so so the reason it's lemon
pores because it was the size of a lemon
and I'd throughout that process it was
normal to begin with and it gradually
got bigger to until there was this
mismatch and you end up justifying to
yourself ah ah there's always been a
slight difference in size or whatever
and then it has to take someone else to
say no no come on you've got three times
affinity so when to the GP they have a
feel than they tell you know use it
appears to be quite enlarged and you're
like yeah yeah I'll just refer you to
the radiologist radiologist get some gel
on it calculates the volume twenty
minutes to tell you that it's big
ultrasound very yep enlarged
something if anyone's ever had a ball
ultrasound or a few if you have one
coming up something that they do this is
the nurse will come in tell you to drop
your pants to your knees leave and then
she'll come back and say oh I've got
this tissue to cover your penis for
decency
because of course here this little
journey leads out not our might you have
to do this don't half-ass it
if you're gonna do it do it properly I'm
quite glad that you're happy to hear
this again because I feel like relieved
most people get if you really say it was
just the story I buy so they cover your
penis for decency of course cuz you
that's the that's the thing that's top
on your mind doing like you sausage roll
is a whole industry so okay so then you
start there with just testicles exposed
they I realized like I'm trying to do
this as like a public relations message
to encourage men who have any kind of
testicular problems to go out and seek
help but it's probably not really
advertising it very well you essentially
it was the trustee dick look like Casper
because the tissue as well will it be
penis and then ball yeah so like it just
really highlights the fact that you have
one so ultrasound a passed a few passed
around a few different people eventually
to the urologist this is the guy who's
gonna operate big Nigerian man starts
examining me and then walks over to the
line without explaining what he's doing
turns it off and comes back with a torch
and shines a light through the ball and
it lights up like a Christmas light he
looks really happy and says you see this
it means it's not the cancer you're like
oh great okay so he's really pleased
about it later on found out us that's
called a trans elimination to check for
for any kind of cancer so that was good
news if I might sir
by this point it was getting pretty big
like the size of a
little steroidal lemon mango mango it
was small mango yeah and it was it gets
to the point everything else like a
rests on it and like you couldn't hide
it in work trousers I did a competition
in the in a singlet and obviously
setting up for bench whoever filmed me
chose to use the diagonal like straight
up towards it and I had to cover poem
down the pipe had to cover it up with a
text box on the bench message from
Johnny the next day saying like great
video but why is the text box so big
emoji of a lemon yeah that would have
been key back matter very much so at
that point been referred for surgery
watched the procedure on YouTube the
night before and started to get the fear
so I went into the shower and tried to
burst it myself and this is where we
turn the lemon into a beam so that
reshapes the lemon it's more of a beam
shape force through force yeah so did
you for that happen was it an initial
like a short sharp like no it was asleep
yeah so you slowly applied the pressure
was it in that position it was your
hands clasped and like interlocked to
get more purchase on it it's just as
well that you're not practiced in
jiu-jitsu you should be really good at
it so had the surgery you Johnny you
tell me much to think about different
ways that you'd be able to squeeze I'm
thinking how I would do it and then
thinking about the amount of pressure
interlace your fingers look is that I
think so even to list your fingers you
can't do that I mean you could really
bear down and apply apply a fair bit of
pressure though I mean you yourself
limited obviously like really yeah
how'd this which is a normal ball I
think slightly yeah it may be slightly
more because there's a lot more pressure
when he went in
they say that's not the shape it was
last time was it no I they've been there
but they didn't notice but went in for
surgery if you've ever been for surgery
as well they draw a big like big L or a
big R and an arrow pointing to the side
that needs operated on if it's if they
do surgery or anything that has to so
kidneys legs
yeah which does feel silly if you have
like a really obvious deformity but
anyway woke up from the surgery on
oxycodone very powerful opiate that
makes it quite to various and talking
nonsense to the nurses coming to the
consultant came up and said okay so you
need to avoid sexual activity for at
least a few days you're like okay great
because I was gonna just go home and try
it out but I think that that was sarcasm
you definitely do not in this kind of
bloody jockstrap Dennis it's very
painful and bleeding so but I guess they
they have to tell people that because
people try they one of the consultants
who installed a colostomy bag on someone
which is like a an anus on the front of
your abdomen basically like a re reroute
in your intestine I've had to revise the
patient postoperatively not to have sex
through the hole this is clearly because
some patient in the past would have
tried and complicated things like I
think complicated and really like if
somebody tries to have sex with a small
fleshy famous type hole idiot than your
side
I imagine created by a man in the
scalpel it's not just a little incision
okay yeah they just take a bit of bowel
and move it up superficially to face or
someone's just reading rounding it
terrible
so that's the story
this isn't should we save the aftermath
for part two yeah maybe because there
are two beeping chronic cast The
Chronicles of Papo Papo yet a lot more
pop one all we talked about his
testicles suffer at the end of the day
the moral of the story is if you have a
problem like this it's only gonna get
worse
until you seek medical help so seek help
seek what purpose the purpose don't try
and pop it yourself see the GP don't be
embarrassed about it
it's a typical male thing to not do that
I was lucky it was a lemon ball but it
could be a nasty ball so and if it is a
nasty ball that can be fatal so field
your ball go to see the GP there's a
really wholesome message to that story
which is that men are often afraid to go
to the doctor for things maybe cut
socio-cultural reasons but that is proof
that you shouldn't be going to doe names
just use your own testicle don't try and
pop it just go and so you just go and
see a professional and they can keep
they'll squeeze in the young they will
squeeze it for you so I hope you enjoyed
that story it was it was unbelievable
the rest of that episode by the way it
was total [ __ ] but that 10-minute period
was I thought it was great we all
prepare those and notes it was it was
only bad because of the audio quality
and the like tapping and miss Kazue get
akia immense FOMO when there's a piece
of content that's created and is we
prepared hard for that it's like life
fails that was just lost in the ether so
thank you massive thank you to everyone
who tuned in 100 episodes we are 60
million less in minutes several thousand
subscribers all that sort of stuff and
we've got some cool questions so we're
gonna do some questions
Johnny trying to do one yours first
Johnny I mean this is very like you know
my first question but questions for
dummies now I don't mean if you have any
favorite novels
well first question as well are we doing
that kind of yeah Chris em hunt why I
may have just take the piss out this
question it's a great question Chris do
you have any favorite novels and then
also do you see any value in reading for
pleasure mmm
those are topher both of these things
have been discussed with Chris sparks
spoke to him about this either day
productivity coach because this is
episode 100 and I'm starting to back up
that's almost definitely going to be
coming after this so either in the past
or the future listen listen uh what
we're talking about well everything's
either in the past or the future
apart from now now right now and now for
now but I'm not that but now so 1984
George Orwell like really good easy read
a lot of implications that you can if
you're a bit of a self development sort
of buff that you can take and apply to
your own life at the Alchemist Paulo
Coelho great novel was the second part
do you see any value in reading for
pleasure absolutely yeah I think that
I've learned 1984 taught me a lot more
and a lot of those conclusions about
bigger impact on my life than reading a
lot of self-help and productivity books
as Chris Fox said it
90% of self-help and productivity books
are a twenty page blog post in 190 180
pages of examples so often got any one
idea ISM as well by one meaningful
concept and then the rest of its just
fluff which is why I like book summary
services for those kind of books can be
really good but then you do have the
time and attentions you don't have any
context well then did that one thing how
the holds last meaning cuz I pass the
teachers just concentrate when you're
working that's deep work yeah basically
the whole thing is when you work is true
but about you
novels I know that you saw a massive I
don't know I'm starting to do it more I
don't do it very much I used to read
quite a bit so pleasure when I was
younger um I read like the Harry Potter
books I read like the Philip Pullman's
stuff they were good yeah
behind my house it's dark materials
really unnecessary methods bring out the
full thing I'm looking forward to that
definitely
yeah because they absolutely butchered
Northern Lights it would there was an
old film of Northern Lights and it was
yeah horrendous human so Albert Camus
the stranger written by someone whose
mum was deaf and he was brought up in it
in echo like really weird like silent
environment and you can feel that in his
writing
not tonight before very good brave new
world and what was the other one I
thought the other one deep work what
come the young I think I watch films
more than uh okay needful things by
Stephen King why did you why I want I
said phone so sorry to interrupt
no it's okay just because it was one of
the best books that I've read but the
film is one of the worst films that I've
seen and so I think they just because
there was a lot of subtext in the book
and then they managed to just record
yeah why sure I like love great book
great film
apparently the big short book I've just
heard this right is fantastic really
yeah that's the sort of thing
I love it yeah great yeah we did get
into it they go at the cinema so like
people read for pleasure often to like
you know moving to another world
I go to Center for art you're
transported kind of conky phone you have
to sit more to I spoke to someone the
other day who went on a Oh Mike did a 4d
cinema except I've got a few of those
they spray with water yeah and I can see
vibrates and awful I don't like I just
like to be left alone to do away with
Agra free apostles and said he was
soaked by the end of it yeah
smelly water as well for either to
Denzel Washington it's a good guy right
um Sean J what is a life hack you
couldn't go without since introducing it
so we need to pick one that you've heard
or you brought up on a life hacks and
you haven't you haven't stopped since
you've done that one I know what you
were gonna say yeah what's he gonna say
- split between physical and digital
what you're gonna say what do you think
you'll say Alfred Oh God
oh you're gonna say out for it but that
actually tops it if I had to pick what I
was gonna say and honor it I'll have to
pick up so if I just out like packed
here oh yeah what was your original shop
duffer Oh
the bombs actually but yeah I try not to
poo
but I'm not at home not because it's
just me holding it well you shouldn't
but it makes the experience so much bad
what you mean you shouldn't you
shouldn't hold in poo longer than you
should live longer than you have to but
no one ever holds in Poona longer than
they have to I think they do because
otherwise he would just pill it's not
longer than they are have to but longer
than they would like to but yeah if you
really like feeling full and you like to
see you like we're like a purely worse
what about you man what you think I
don't know what about cupola any come to
mind I'll tell you what's interesting
Sean great good quite good question one
of the things that we find is that the
little cycles that we go through it's
like a natural evolution of life hacks
and over time some will remain and many
will be discarded so a lot of them I
almost need to go back in caveat like
101 and 102 and 103 that I no longer do
wrong what it's not good for my spine
given my current Speidel
I did a Whooper Bunge review that now
I'm not doing that and now I'm
considering getting the three like so
I've been in gone out and then come back
again you get the flip side as well
where the Sun that's so standard in your
life now that you forget that they're
even automatic are such as control
probably the the life hack then like the
master hack is to just be constantly
iterating an experiment because like all
of us
there were hope the reason for life
hacks is like we're all trying something
new every time you speak every other day
my eel I feel like how can they like
changing or something yeah so air pods
are probably there up there yeah fairly
ubiquitous in my life yeah like pins out
Wi-Fi scales and you know I except we've
mentioned that I don't it's just part of
my dad that's the thing it's when the
ones that why is a life hack you
couldn't go with
since introducing it it's the ones that
integrate the most seamlessly with your
life that's why you like Alfred that's
why we mainly like air pods for me the
best one the one that has given me the
highest return single highest return
from one life AK sleeping with my phone
outside of my room if you put your phone
outside of your room when you before you
go to bed or if you have a bedroom ban
on your phone
mm-hmm is the downstream from that it's
the same as getting a dog
happiness water fresh air would like
downstream all the implications are
great yeah so yeah phone outside of the
room Johnny I still don't do that me too
I can do it so this is just based on
recently the Byron Katie book the Byron
Katie process I think that was a life
hack really yeah just like lately been
using it for I think if you are able I'm
not I'm not so convinced now that it's
like having this deep sort of like
rewiring effect but it just allows you
to take something live like when you
wake up in the morning and I really
pissed off about it you just reframe it
see you differently and use it to your
advantage the process which works for
you exactly and if you can take a bad
thing right well I'm just gonna do this
about it then it's great thing huh it's
also great because if it eliminates
boredom forever like me if you're
soundin ridges around for ten hours you
can be like biome coat yummy yeah barn
Katie buddy end on technology you feel
amazing yeah Casper it's Mike it's not
good Chris excuse me excuse me sorry
unbelievable Emma James Petey um I think
wanted a date with you actually I
probably should have said that but
serasa Chris but would you rather have
to tell everyone around you that you
need to fart or pee your pants
and she's submitted in a second question
ellipsis every day so so would you
rather have to tell everyone around you
that you need to farm so every time you
fall apart or just every time you pee
your pants it's a fun gotta be fun like
it or else you just pissing your pants
all the time yeah it states that there's
not made no icing there's a
dryer as the yeah I suppose it depends
on if you need to fart it's like every
time you even get a hint of the feeling
you have to fight I don't have the hint
of a fart much like mine earth they just
fall out of it false alarms about false
alarms at all you must have situations
in your IP we think I shouldn't fart you
what the only time that I think I
shouldn't fart is when I think I might
shart
but you must be the social setting where
you're like I shouldn't fire I know a
lot of you know what we've been in long
car journeys with you and you've been
very very good but that's because of the
seating position so it's not so it's not
it's not okay Casper Sorenson how much
to journey in you sit really bench I
love that he's got serene in his name
it's kind of some of the letters
Sorenson must watch you what's your
all-time PB nah comp one 62.5 was there
any comp
no he said not to come it was it in a
club no no so just in the gym yeah
peeking yeah this was before this was in
the build-up of prior to me going right
in some part of thing you got 172 in
gold star it was very no it wasn't it
wasn't gone so it was in David Lloyd and
if we can not have called it a badge
price
okay so like dodgy plates like bench
height was questionable and it was like
crushing on my sternum
because it wasn't like a fleegle
Johnny's not counting it but I would say
purity money's still of the Splane yeah
it's like well I mean there's infinite
examples if you see what side versus the
world yes
it ought love just Louie Simmons man
cool go you know the new me Simmons has
never done a podcast yeah and I'm trying
you know unbroken you think he's
unbroken buzzie yeah but I think he's
pretty hard to get a hold on yeah I'm
trying to get Bronco that's it at the
start of the West is the world it says
like this was not Louise idea and then
the shifts go
I've seen him you know the barbell shrug
guys I've seen him take the barbell
shrug guys I'm struggling with my clean
and lives just like bands so it gets the
barbell shrug guy to do a bandit power
clean and like obviously you get that
you do the pole and it just
she sounds like much less to move faster
he just gets to go to behind apart lanes
in between us Lucy Simmons is a boy set
but best match across 150 what I was in
pinnacle yeah yeah was it yeah what we
went in Rio every Wednesday because
there was a leaderboard and we just yeah
just turned up talked everything in all
all genders and all weight categories
yeah
identified as everything when how much
do you bench somewhere else is that you
sneak us up yes um well my all-time pb's
140 but I don't train back that'll be
great first great flat back feel on the
bench all of those memos for eight reps
be mine cuz he never went below eight
you got got this but Jetta moon has
hammered the questions I've got a lot of
them that's like you just injected me
what's something you think every person
should experience in their lifetime I
hope to be on a podcast be on a podcast
I think that that's a really good answer
I think that at some point in your life
especially now a lot of distraction a
lot of time spent double screaming
triple screaming and watching TV being
distracted not having deep conversations
it is like doing these podcasts and
having these discussions with whoever is
now even people I got not that much like
Brian Carol is a 300 and something pal
pal if it from Florida and the only
thing I have in common is we've both
been seen by the same back specialist
and an hour and a half talking to just
flew by I loved it and he'd I'm gonna go
see and I'm gonna go chill with him and
you're like the opportunity aren't
believer you're going to go and chill
with Brian kaoru-dono I've got taped a
on in a couple of weeks he will be an
interesting guy I've got a way for you
to get questions from um Andrew Doyle
sat down under Doyle this Sunday went
out for him in Edinburgh last night
after his show the Fringe had drinks on
it
like young pokers it's on the podcast
indeed so to be on a podcast be your
podcast just have the opportunity or if
not sit down with someone for
one hour both phones outside of the room
and I have a discussion about something
that you think will interest you
so like faker podcast I just think
having deep conversations with people
you both leave everyone that's apart
from leaves the room better than when
you went that's why it's like it you can
do a podcast about whatever you're
interested in and just put it on iTunes
like this the costs at some point on
this one will do it when alone but yeah
right have a say to yourself that you
can't do a podcast
what because cost is the reason
especially when you are part of a radio
station and the content is made and it's
been edited and mastered and you're just
thinking of a way to repurpose it right
well I want something that everyone
should experience and we don't make her
experience so that doesn't have to be it
wouldn't make it which is so seriously
yeah this is exactly what I was gonna
say the squats it was squat when I make
it well so it's one office is exactly
what I was gonna say it really Brown
little evil so sorry
so the Widowmaker is a set of squats
with your 10 rep marks and you do 20 and
obviously by definition anything that's
not possible but it is possible it just
takes 10 minutes to do yeah and so you
have the bar on your back you do 10 you
you're done you keep the Barney back you
take 5 to 10 deep breaths you go again 5
to 10 deep breaths you go again until
you hit 20 you start to go death
you have ringing in your ears blood you
yeah like everything just shuts out and
like all your cares drop away and you
the whole being is just like I hate this
other ways to experience it 10-minute
ice bath high-dose psychedelics if
that's what you're into 2 K max Rho 2 K
max were 10-day meditation retreat like
anything that they're all quite
different versions of I think of
widow-makers very like it's the shortest
way to do harm visceral get away from it
yeah ok my tits 2 K max raah yeah max
the guys at Jim Jones the guys who
trained all the 300 actors they call the
the to Cairo like the the test a
horrible distance away seven many people
well do we know the story about the
selfie you're one here we think it was
that first to Cairo it's better yeah
Johnny what's yours listen I mean that
I'll make it that was gonna be it like
so I think the thing that a lot of
people don't experience I think everyone
should is experiencing a high end or the
end of your physical capability
experience the line where your mind is
like shutting you to stop I think as
well what you've identified with the
Widowmaker is that because the way the
programming is done like we've always
said this about powerlifting if you
can't lift the weight you can't lift the
weight doesn't go up there's no struggle
yeah
whereas if you've ever been if you ever
watch one of those videos where boxers
run out of gas and then they kind of
collapse to the floor it's a how would
you have to be to not be able to throw
another punch yeah I yeah it's the
weight of your arm not even going
against gravity
that's like thousand cuts is just
extending your arm oh yeah exactly so
it's it's the thing I've always admired
like I always admire always admired
early athletes have always admired like
Special Forces and it's not physical
prowess it's it's like being able to the
ability to just tolerate does it go
against that was running on his David
got me yeah this David Goggin the one
who broke his feet and was still gonna
yeah yeah just like frightening people
terrifying people who were able to do
like oh wow this is a [ __ ] belt or a
question Paul Hogan if you were to give
your student self we'll call this first
student like fresher 18 if you were to
give your student self a life hack what
would it be
when I think about how different my life
syrup is now to when I was 18 jeez
because when I was 18 phones weren't a
problem so wouldn't he yeah adoption
stuff and thing is no Pomodoro's would
be good for me being a student but
probably already care
and you've got to assume like you came
out with you degree so that's gonna
happen any unless your life hat makes
that harder yeah 5x5 would be probably
something that I wish I'd known I just
should have done more days why are you
did 5x5 you're not wrong like of like 31
but yeah so five I think like sitting
down and explaining to my 18 year old
self just like nutrition the treatment
we does so many stupid diet a
nutritionist what was our supposing that
alone would have saved me hundreds of
hours probably of my degree and pounds
of wasted money
I'm like surge work out from the
Anaconda protocol indigo 3G there's a
little place everyone's own into
graffiti as a game changer what about
Yusef one thing to have enough and then
you wouldn't have lost you Journal of
like a decade oh yeah so I wrote journal
for a daily journal for a decade and
then one day my Microsoft Word file
corrupted I just thought well there's no
point in continuing like I just really
say it was like the most autistic oh
yeah identification of the day yeah it
was like when he met this person ate
fish it wouldn't be an interesting room
well it probably would scroll back over
you huh oh yeah like you know the most
month there's so many Monday and days in
your life it's just the mind you sure
yeah what about you Johnny oh sorry
would be Evernote and Evernote was good
deep were a deep work habit if the book
existed 531 very similar like a rep
scheme but I think for me it would be
just raising my standards because I in
my first degree thought that I was like
some big hotshot like doing really well
but looking back like it was a degree
that like if you didn't get a first in
it your dick so and then the second one
made me realize that how much slack
there wasn't this
and actually what I could have done is
done to two degrees at the same time I
want independent one one private one
University one or like learned another
language read loads of books like start
up another business like something that
so yeah Johnny I think either it sort of
incentivizing myself to like go down the
path of seeking alternative education
earlier so I think like I stumbled into
like is the trader eighteen well yeah I
mean stuff like that like you know the
stuff that you start the into the self
developing world and read books and
listen to different people and get
different views that different from your
friends and different for what your
parents are talking different from
school and I think the earlier you get
that the better your life decisions are
but I don't know I don't think it's not
as a life hack necessarily but I think
like just start learning from places
that aren't even that would have been
what I was almost home you got one
Johnny
Goodwin what personality trait has
gotten you them in the most trouble
trouble hmm out of the big five probably
right probably in your asses or
industries discover so left over price
nuances much neuroticism or so this is
caused the most problems for me
is somewhere between neuroticism and
industriousness just that I can't I
can't bear not to be working and doing
things like a needs getting I'm
controlling it better but the
industriousness is getting worse
I'm able to now operate with less rest
right like less downtime I'm able to do
that previously it might be a five-day
week but now I can probably get away
with maybe a seven-day week before I
need to take an afternoon and then you
know over time that will be coming like
a 10-day week Murat's need to take an
afternoon so the problem with that is
that back in the day when you're honest
ISM caused me to shortcut success as the
indicator for my success and just
allowed I was forced to use the
suffering associated with the task
as my indicator of I've done good so if
I worked a club night and went home one
was [ __ ] I would think yeah you've
worked hard irrelevant of regardless of
the of the success of the event whereas
I could go and have a one where I live a
performed really well wave hadn't
suffered I was like oh you're arcing
lazy but it has to be hard to be to feel
like you're moving right there even if
it's not successful and then if it's not
so you need to you need to succeed on
two different pathways and one of which
is not associated with success at all
yeah so yeah that that's kind of the one
that's got me in the most trouble it's
also gotten the most trouble with
friends girlfriends all that sort of
stuff
why are you working again this evening
why are you doing this it means that you
don't have a rare person who wants to
work as much as we do an ex fortunate
that we are around each other and like
[ __ ] Dean's the same Jordan George
you know a lot of people that we saw
I've come across I wouldn't know how
much if the fact that my friends is just
as desperately not feeling quite a
jovial normal yeah what about Yusef that
last it was very good answer similar
similar for me it's my overhead press
like it's always been slow to progress
and then um my sister where it's all
nice no I am agreeableness as well I
mean it's that or a ton of the the
problem that I see not your problem too
agreeable I think so in like but
neuroticism as well like that I think
yours has got to be it's gonna be
problem well yeah which comes about the
ganja agreeableness and you see the
groomers is it not save money on rock
the boat so that was no problem not rock
the boat is agreeable I suppose yeah and
then save money
you're obviously I'm less bothered about
saving money these days right you are
getting better not because I'm family so
he used by you yeah I'm just like it's
your threshold for seeing value but that
is also both of your influence we pull
you out of there yeah what about you
Johnny cuz this isn't trust however you
the probably the biggest one for me is
boundaries and what I mean by that is um
I will so similar to your suppose like I
would love to be
able to shut my laptop at 4 o'clock and
go train and forget about work for us
today but no matter how many times I
tell myself to do that I can't so I need
I need to force boundaries on myself but
that also leads to me being like I'm
late for stuff or I'll procrastinate
with things sometimes and do them right
the last minute it's really bad I
thought Unni like I would do all my
projects right at the last minute as
well I like the developer of frozen
turkey like it's got into her yeah it's
and knows that I think everyone does it
like everyone procrastinate on simcha
it's just the I partly I suppose I hold
myself to a really high standard with
everything which is stupid and I don't
allow myself any like a leeway for just
being human being yes that's something
that I think you're very good at and
like I know some urban songs about like
rewiring your brain to like look for the
most difficult thing of the day and just
when you're home in on it is let's say
you've got like 10 minutes before you
have to go out mmm I'd be like ah it's
not quite long enough to do like a live
video or whatever you already look good
like don't you do it that pull it that
executor versus strategist thing's a big
deal like a chump I haven't completed
right I got a jar sorry I'm really good
with executing that I like put a little
washing it off across the net yeah weird
like it's because there's no reward
toaster right like like if it's like
it's like all this really complex
pumpkin bring on my uh I'll sit and do
it for three hours Johnny did the dishes
but if it's like Johnny viewed like
unloaded the difficult shot why don't we
do a couple of a couple of quickfire
ones then we got a really really good I
mean you know what Johnny's most and
least favorite CrossFit movements except
squats and deadlifts least favourite is
running in burpees okay look so okay so
the way separated is if I have to move
something while being stationed we
really enjoy it if I have to move myself
I don't enjoy it typically so like
pull-ups I find hard toast about hard
there if he's hard running extremely
hard running she just be remove from
CrossFit entirely if it's like rowing
Echo bike any of the barbell anything
the dumbbell bring it up
what about a dumbbell box step overs
you've done those yeah box step overs
yeah so - twenty-two and a half so I
need the in either hand just step over
the box don't need to step up at the top
just get over it is the most glooty
thing you've ever done in your life size
of that pretty bad process ugly no you
can do however like you know most people
go straight on then twisting to actually
thrust as I hate anything front rack is
so lacks a new thing on there another
quick one fitness aims for 2020 eirick
the open rx the open yeah that's a
[ __ ] great aim you know like just as
something I want to be able to go all of
the fundamental movement hmm I know what
I want to you know place I I heard see
you Reverend see I'm Middleton so he
spoke about um like you have a a flame
inside you which is like you or like
enthusiasm for things and he's like
everybody gets to a point in our life
where the flame starts to this is a
really long one thing flame starts to
flicker out and die he's like what you
got to do at that point is reignite the
flame and the as he said that better
look the main one that's what you're
doing isn't who that's like I've never
thought about it before but like at that
time I just signed up as I just don't
six months across fit and I could feel
the flame flickering with about the
fitness in general like nutrition
couldn't give a [ __ ] training boring
mobility don't care whereas now I get
switched and suddenly like I love
training again and like it doesn't
matter that it did you didn't give two
years ago I told myself up so I think
that I think the I really want to do
like a long content piece on this
because I think people two things are
annoying one is I don't think CrossFit
is what everyone wants it to be I think
it's a sport I think it's a great way of
expressing like holding you Fitness into
something but I think there are other
attributes that you should be focusing
on as well in other ways I've trained a
sensible that I D be feeding the
CrossFit but also people who just
relentlessly criticize things in the
fitness industry having never tried them
like we say all the time like Kido [ __ ]
he ever try kyo like how long did on
keto for onion which are how how
convenient for Haley
prepare for like we we've done have
thrown our so likely delay on the train
tracks I'm like is it raining killing me
I don't know we'll find out like because
I just people like lay in the CrossFit
and we used to do it and then I was like
well we can't keep doing this and
because you try to the wall in class
I don't you do classes both
vomit-inducing people in the gym really
got here and Tim Briggs still talks
about to this perpetuate you're always
on the podcast yeah fitness center 2023
flares on the floor so flares when you
in trouble on scene you have to UM that
you will have seen people do on the
pommel horse where legs are wide moving
yeah yeah advanced this is so hard if
you've got one I've seen you do one I've
just nailed to on the floor well not be
a third gonna be really difficult to get
yeah but I just fought because what I'm
doing with the two is that I'm basically
I just coasting on the momentum from
just winging myself round but it's it's
bad form so so what you have to do to do
that like how do you just do more
because if you don't do two Flyers right
you need to leave it so ya can't train
flat both legs like up alongside you
your face sorry what I mean is like how
do you train for that so I got a
mushroom from eBay weight which I've
been doing but it forces you into bad
habits because they obviously you know
got lazy
yeah because your legs can go below the
floor so actually you learn it you
almost ingrained it a wrong technique
you in green one that's good for pommel
horse but not for floor so now I'm
forcing on getting more lift and just
like try you you do have to be able to
get into like a really comfortable
pancake like active as well so ours but
simplex has just been able to like to do
that and then triceps shoulders as well
yeah this is why this is why just some
[ __ ] they're so impressive I we
went I went to a handstand workshop with
James Bailey and the guy called you Val
Avalon who is a ex Israeli Olympic
Gymnastics now like I got hands done it
monster like just as no forces special
for he's like 50 years old is in
incredible shape and he someone asked
him a hard
left which is you know he's like when
you legs are wide on the floor you put
your hands on the floor and he lifts
into a handstand
yeah and he did it like a beautiful one
and then he was like it's not about
strength look at this and he did one but
on the floor so he sat down had his hop
had his feet up in front of him like the
knights degrees lean forward and then
slid his feet all the way around so he
was just lying on his front and then
brought his feet back round again so
he's south again yeah so he was like my
hips have just got the full yeah fully
gyroscopic who's like if you can do that
then you're not actually lifting you're
just putting your hands on the floor he
already flat you all we have to do is
just lift your legs up so mine I just
need to be able to train again one like
this so is that the out his honor okay
like that's what you're moving towards
my fitness aim for the end of 2020 would
be able to do rx all of the CrossFit
movements at forty kilos if there's way
on it pain free and without fear so
currently I'm not lifting I don't do
anything I kept just doing my rehab and
it's a [ __ ] destitute place to be if
someone who's used to training but these
are the sacrifices that I need to make
and people like Brian Carol splits
[ __ ] sacrum in half front to back and
went back and he's now gonna try and
squat a thousand two hundred pounds at
275 to be the first man on the planet
has ever done it like it stop [ __ ]
complaining your problem is not as bad
as you think it is you're still able to
do some things it's a good arch you suck
it up and crack on I'm consistently
impressed with your boredom tolerance
for the big three or four doing any
rehab movements like you're going to the
gym and just do rehab but that would
drive me mentally it's actually because
I'm very selfish it's because I want to
train I want to train so badly that I'm
prepared to do something super boring to
here with the training yeah so it's just
a lot like a I'm almost surprising
myself for that long-term is mental also
by the powerlifting will is probably the
biggest example of people who like Lane
Orton dinged is back like three times I
think right before me and there's videos
of him like you just keep saying brick
brick by brick brick by brick so you
like work so it was like does 304 a
double back goes again
right back to doing like bird dogs and
Rangers the whole building it might go
place was because keep going
you need a few years in Donegal my
recommendations for the best wearable
fitness tech so you have gone back to oh
you've gone back to where in a week
month why OOP quick one why mainly
because when you're doing powerlifting
the only thing that's relevant for it
really is HIV so the strain the strange
may be mainly a cardio measure like your
heart rate zones and other things so I
just it's just in trust really plus then
you move on have you ordered the new
strut yeah is it arriving soon yeah I'll
be interesting when I saw ordered the
boot 300k cuz that's so they said they
sent me a thing saying if you just
resupply
we'll send you with three formation so
that want like three things do you have
any wearable Fitness of all winnings
quitting's oh yeah the with it so so
Chris kindly gave me a winnings watch
which is good just tres it's very it's
like first gen so it's just tracks heart
rate is so thin and I know it's even
snow it's not very good
I want to get on a train or a ring
George so he would lend me his see
whether I like you out of my buy one I
use Annie's headband for meditation just
so I am which is what for so much the
view okay so I mean that it's very good
for a certain style of meditation they
claim that the new gen accounts for more
like heart orientation ones like hot
mine stuff okay so you can do different
styles it does it certainly does
correlate a wearable EEG that you could
correlate with the level of
concentration that you have and what was
the other one there's a heart math
Institute device I think you wear around
your chest
yeah though I'm interested in buying
this $200 but I'm not math if you
listening just send this one out will do
right I'll be lovely but I need to
justify that to myself by using them use
more consistently yeah I think like even
just Fitbit just bang I think there's no
there's no downside just having
something mmm I need what I need is
something as comfortable as a whoop
which gives me the same readout of it
but as the time yeah I just need to hone
in time at the time because if I had
something that
it's displaylist if I ever had something
that had the time when I wouldn't need
to get my phone out to check the time
and then you're looking for yeah so so
you know you're thinking to get a new
would put but I'm gonna try the three
cuz I did like the reader on that and
I've noticed that I'm not taking as much
care about my sleep because I sleep with
my phone out of the room which means I
can't use sleep cycle and also I can't
track what sort of quality my sleep is
through sleep ranges the biggest thing
for me is just wearing it more like a
watch position so I was obsessive you
know they recommend like wearing up here
I wrote like I was obsessed with that
and it was making it fit weird for me
didn't you want the new one of the new
struggle be better this very quick one
at what point do you draw the line when
it comes to the trade-off between
personal data and personalised /
tracking services eg wearable tech I
just think as soon as as soon as it
takes up more than a couple of minutes a
day just [ __ ] it off like if I think
what that question is asking I think is
like privacy yeah Oh giving you stuff
away I think oh [ __ ] yes of course it is
sorry Alfie I'm [ __ ] mad at my house
yes
I don't yeah yeah I don't go [ __ ]
however 23andme and ancestry and stuff
like that hmm
partly there's some people dodgy shared
by those there's some people that gang
convicted for crimes or if they're
commits because they're able to find the
genetic profile through that which is
like ah that's scary [ __ ] right we got a
good one here mr. Sun shrew I asked this
already with my own answer but
interested to hear your threes living 20
plus years under the idea that we aren't
admired for the depths of our perception
in reference to Chris's favorite
writings Alain de Botton on the high
degree of loneliness and its inexorable
part of being a sensitive intelligent
human do you feel the greater investment
and depth of progress in modern wisdom
and correlating practice the more
compounded the sense of loneliness for
one of a better word follow-up do those
ignorant out do you think ignorance
really would be bliss does he mean
ignorant from the obviously you don't
know but like is it ignorance from a
perspective of the roots of
self-improvement so the question the
main question here is do you feel the
greater investment and depth of progress
in modern wisdom and
in practice the more compounded the
sense of loneliness in well I mean I
suppose in the in the most basic sense
like there are fewer and fewer people
who have relatable experiences yeah yeah
it's a good question yeah I understand
what you're asking so the the Alain de
Botton video from the school of life
which is why we're fate to be lonely
basically says that people who have a
subtle country or allowing points of
view less likely to be accepted by
society at large because of the mimetic
nature of us as beings and the fact that
we're tribe lomi want to be accepted
given the choice between honesty and
acceptability most of us will compromise
our honesty in order to be accepted by
people that were around and the that
long and short of that is that a lot of
people compromise who they are so that
they can be around people that aren't
like them but just so they're around
people and like I I did that for a very
long time the bottom line is and it's
the thing that we continue to come back
to with everybody that speak to
absolutely everyone from Andrew Doyle
the guy that created Tanya McGrath sam
Harris wrote an entire book on it John
Pierce and it's one of his number one
rules
tell the truth and if you're telling the
truth you can't do that you have to
follow whatever that particular calling
is you have to do the thing which calls
to you and for me personally the more
tools that I've got in my toolbox the
better I've been actually being
effective because most sense of solitude
not loneliness the time that I spend on
my own I love like there are fewer and
fewer people that I can really really
genuinely connect with about everything
that I do but there are more people that
I can connect with about some things
that I do yeah there's more arms to what
I can talk about I can now go talk about
back health
I mean genuinely have an hour-long
conversation about back health I
couldn't have done that before aside
learning things I think um it's the same
as hike a business serving a niche right
like if you try and serve everyone you
end up serving no one I think you the
people you end up meeting as a result of
just going down the route of modern
wisdom
and the conversations you end up having
like if you put us three in a bar for an
evening you know you've got to sit in
the bar and just talk about whatever you
want like how much of our time would we
spend talking about like surface-level
pointless conversation like it would all
be like it some really deep like that
other people walking over the [ __ ] you
talking about like but we aren't you end
up talking about like the finest details
of something that were really interested
in that other people make things weird
but we're all having the best
conversation ever because it's something
we're interested in so you might either
have like talk about like match of the
day or something that you really really
care deeply passionate about what you
suffer do you think it's yeah it's
something you have to make a choice
about whether you are just hung around
with people for the sake of being with
people and if you're compromising on who
you are for that I think you need to
really ask yourself the question of
maybe it's better to actually withdraw
and you know pursue what you what you
love and the think about embed yourself
in the thoughts and pursuits that you
enjoy and then you will find people that
resonate like we're in an age where you
can find people like that so easily now
if you are someone that is feeling
lonely and not something you're aware of
I think personally I've not felt
loneliness for a long time because I
think my life is very much the opposite
like I'm just getting pounded wherever
right wherever I go like turn up at work
and you just like your photos go mental
and beat you or is in demand and you
come you come home and you you know your
messages and your phone and everything's
like so I think for me I also very much
value just alone time because it's like
ah the difference of so I love car new
pots definition of solitude which is
time away from the input of other
people's thoughts yeah and there's
difference between being on your own and
solitude because you can have all of
these things with with and without
loneliness but most people don't
actually have solitude they have their
phone with them while they're on their
own while they're on their own but with
the TV on or with the radio on or
whatever it is
it's not necessarily solitude solitude
would be you with no other stimulus
other than you on output journaling on
and if you're always trying to escape
that loneliness by like having something
on in the background or whatever then I
suppose that's where you go to ask
yourself the question of do I need to
sit and think about hang on what can i
what am I not engaging with or what I
what should I be engaging with mentally
that is and I'm avoiding the follow-up
of would ignorance be blessed John
Peterson said this at his live show long
story short he says that the thing which
poisoned - you need to take enough up
for it to be a toxic to turn a toxin
into a tank and he says that the
progression through these particular
issues is not a regression it's more it
take more of why it is that you think
that poison to you until it becomes a
tonic that fixes you so anyone who knows
the allegory of the cave Plato's
allegory of the cave it's that exact
story so just go listen to Plato's
allegory of the cave then you'll
understand exactly what I mean I don't
think ignorance is bliss
like some people coast through life but
it is both a blessing and a curse to
feel everything so very deeply like and
what that fukk me I would much sooner be
able to appreciate the beauty of
everything with real fidelity and then
have to suffer a little bit because you
don't really live your life on the couch
just chilled out [ __ ] within this the
tightest into quartile range of human
experience like I'm much sooner die
enough highs and lows than have just
constantly lived in a better comfort the
bigger I think the biggest example of
this for me was leaving corporate life
like leaving nine-to-five life from
being entrepreneur thrown into the
[ __ ] ether yeah is that it like it's
quite a lonely experience at a times
especially if like you sat by yourself
something bad happens on you computer
screen and it like sends you into this
emotional they might be just there on
your own you've got to sit with that
experience whereas like as an employee I
would the analogy I would say is like as
an entrepreneur you're like in a dinghy
on the on the top of the the sea while
there's a storm happening if you're an
employee you're like on the riverbed and
someone goes Gina's a storm up there
[ __ ] I saw someone's like some sort
it wears what I get
really
[ __ ] great yeah so like you know and
then you're like well you have moments
where like it would be easier just so
that what I think ignorant is bliss for
me the thing I think of is well just go
sit in an office and like check the
people about love island and that's
obviously I'm very I'm generalizing but
like versus sat by yourself looking at a
computer screen [ __ ] terrified with a
spoon trouble try to the top
life isn't live from the comfort you
couch one I got one very very keen to
hear mister Sandshrew if you have any
examples normal or very silly we're
ignorant would be bliss because I'd like
it's only it's a great thought
experiment like are there any situations
where date of death say a method of
death so you reckon that would be you'd
prefer not to know I can't think of a
situation now I'm sure there with beef
where if I written the comments below
we want to ask though I got one more I
got one more before will go back on
yours this is from Andrew Tate he is
very interesting in that personality and
a good online mate of mine can I ask if
true Jordy regrets doing a hit piece on
me now everyone knows he loves dildos oh
dear drone any background of that so
true Jodi's Instagram teams have been
leaked in which he talks at length about
liking to be humiliated about sucking
the dick of a black man after it's being
inside of this girl that he's talking to
about this girl humiliating him and
putting dildos inside of his ass about
him then sucking the dildos after
they've been inside of his own ass who
needs it it was all over Twitter month
because you're not on Twitter but it is
everywhere at the moment and he called
out and Rita and rotated this
ridiculously big tweet about why doesn't
like Star Wars and it went like hyper
viral and Andrew and Laurence when I'm
fairly hard right and Andrews recently
done a
where he's just like just gotta be
careful just be careful exactly what you
said is that man if you've got [ __ ] like
this lurking around
don't come after someone like me I've
done what I don't think it's in the
league tip I think they get a lesson
from that is like people think that when
they type something in iMessage or
whatsapp or Instagram DM that like it's
in this little private world that no
one's gonna [ __ ] screenshot away in
public yeah exactly
what you got give us a little let's do
some quick fry once that's me if you
could have chosen your own name what
would you picked up composite
farm or do you believe in media no no no
like I don't know I'm quite happy with
Youssef it's a very common name in the
Arab world but here is I was going to be
Jonathan we're really what's going to be
Jonathan
no do you wanted that I don't mind
Jonathan Johnson's corner there's one of
the problems that I had with Jonathan is
the number of different ways that there
are yes spell it Jonathan Jonathan
Johanna John Johnny John yeah Johnny
Johnny Johnny Johnny Johnny John the
sort of the Christian connotation of
Christopher logged up others have not
bothered as well as I don't know
I like Johnny I don't like Jonathan but
it's a it's a link to like Jonathan I
like the fact that I've got two versions
of my name's Chris and Christopher did
you get it I suppose you don't have a
short version of your name DSF you but
like it's okay it's an example for one
like let's say you are like someone as a
god know you a bit and they call you
Chris
rather than Christopher do you have
another things like are no so there is a
little Johnny often Utley like if
someone calls me Johnny it's like they
know me it's opposed John yeah do I know
like I seen you on the in them yeah yeah
whereas I thought if I get Jonathan it's
normally in a formal scenario but Johnny
his friends don't so if someone in a
like position of authority calls me
Johnny you're like an example it's just
a good little canary in the coalmine
about where they're at yeah
like to the coaches in class called you
Jonathan but when they're out of class
quality Oh Johnny Johnny that's good
they call me Johnny
what was that do we believe in mediums
yet wisdom do you believe in mediums do
you think there was some actual science
behind their practices no Darren brown
go watch slows it down bro
he went to Iceland and what we did which
was known love it - damn bro I love that
as there was a blizzard are you going to
droves of people is it was it was it are
you going to draw your hair again no the
best type of male underwear grenade wear
or smuggling goods what is the funniest
thing you have ever seen a stranger do
[ __ ] me
I reckon you'll have seen there are
there was one that you said the other
day excuse me I'm not being funny right
got the brain problem that's fairly
funny oh yeah that so many things happen
our events we've been to where at the
time the event isn't that funny for
retrospect to me like [ __ ] hilarious
but I can't non that would like trans
right on here we go it's not as great
believe in mediums by the way deep
yeah but not not anything anyone that
advertises themself to be one isn't one
I think if you're at the point where you
can you're starting to like see glimmers
of things that are outside of you human
reality you'll be deep in a cave
somewhere not really caring about trying
to prove it to anyone so by the time
your medium for anyone listening if
you're medium you will know and you're
gonna be so off the deep end
yeah also right spirit like rubbing your
face on the ground in the weeds like
like what do you have to gain from like
being that are makeup because you have
to dead people
yeah Perales that is a very good point
if you if you're a medium and you have
access to the entire history of all dead
people what the [ __ ] you speaking to
Sharon's month oh yeah god that's so
true [ __ ] Nikola Tesla is out there
and your your giant put it like that it
is completely
ridiculous especially when Bruce Lee all
the people are like well you know
Shannon she's here there's a collie
there's a car guys
someone with an H oh come on and that's
her my you have fought it with yeah it's
just the guy on Darren brown you guys
I'm absolutely hung drawn and quartered
by that's funniest thing you've ever
seen a stranger do it wasn't a stranger
for drove darren home after the stuff
Christmas party couple of years ago and
I saw him throw up on the ground on
Jasmine back road and then as he came up
from throwing up he threw up again
standing upright and the force of him
throwing up laterally pushed him
backwards and he fell over in mud that
was [ __ ] at the time side splitting me
hilarious something that said it related
to that is this this is just something
that occurred to me that was funny at
the time
I was 18 I was in basement in Newcastle
everyone was drinking skills and travels
and we had this thing where it was
called a TP or a tactical puke probably
heard of that tactical chunder he used
to keep going to keep going so we're out
in the alleyway and three of us are
making ourselves be sick successful so
there's everyone's like you know things
down threatens like and then like one
person goes and that encourages number
two to be sick and number three be sick
and there's a guy walking down the alley
at the time boom it's over
not a night out sores bit sick and
consequently I've always been the person
doing the weird thing rather if you do
some fun you think but the I love the
idea of the sympathy bomb cuz it's like
if he can't then blame you oh well you
know when you're up you see someone be
seconds the smell of it
it smells like parmesan right in the
back of your throat what you smell
and then him being sick like making you
want to be sick again and they're using
this self-fulfilling every throne of
ours no that was a very funny Johnny
what we got let's do so let's keep on
moving through these car no not that
someone wants to hear Matt Hawaii wants
to hear your nocturnal emissions story
oh it's in Vipassana 10-day retreat
yeah God last long story short yes it
was on a silent meditation retreat
wasn't allowed to think about sex or you
don't like to watch masturbate
then you got an alien retreat way just
all you thought about was sex yeah was
that the day I think it was the day
after yeah so Daniel Ingram says that
cuz I thought like because I remember
David describing this my date one is
sadness day twos fear day Henry and a
three-sport and I said this a Daniel
Ingram he's like the guy he's like
completed meditation and he was like yes
that's what happens is that Leslie and a
semi of the mind thing everyone has that
exact porn that when desire of emotions
that go through on each of the ten days
I don't think I've ever had a wet dream
a new low and on a meditation the
government now you have them constantly
you've never had me that it's if you've
had a waitress a comment below
yeah I of my friends and I've had this
conversation with anything it's 50/50
split really a quite often for hon
what's going on
I know I mean to come you know carry my
yeah come I did it come in my pants you
woke up in a bunk bed after having gonna
come and then drop kicked a man with
Roman you're a Frenchman you couldn't
speak to him
oh yeah is that because the whole idea
of not making eye contact is that you
don't like [ __ ] with anyone's
tree isn't it leaves there I'm kicked a
man with coming upon for the rest of the
week wherever you walk past him you
burst out laughing like if there's a way
to [ __ ] with someone knocking him relent
what exactly gonna go good meditate
hours a day but all he can think about
is that weird bloke who looks like that
pirate from this [ __ ] matter who look
like Captain Hook
yes if him guy with Smee who keeps stop
me from getting in the Neverland
dropkick right
if using creatine should I use it on non
training days that's just propene
fitness.com for size creatine
yep how's the propane fitness space
program progressing space program that's
a question did we cus personal Sorensen
Casper it's because in your one of your
slides as a foot of a spaceman tumbling
didn't there's a tumblr Jesus Christ is
such a attention in T too high fidelity
attention yeah exactly why his legs why
Johnny's legs so long
herbs from Ross because powerlifting I'm
why why why does that Oh Tom Wilks all
right Tom Wilkes Booth yeah over there
he's even made his last name
powerlifting relative so it's not the
one where anyone's the IPF formula okay
who is the coolest person who listens to
modern wisdom my mum my mum your mum
likes all I share on Facebook is you in
the [ __ ] drain yeah honestly she
biggest about coolest person that you
know that listens to modern wisdom any
killed people that you know that have
said I listen to them I know there's a
lot of people who are meeting in the
CrossFit gym you listen in modern wisdom
you love it no I mean are they all cool
suppose they're sort of a [ __ ] fit if
you had to pick a favorite modern with
some episode from the last 100 that
we've done what would it be
I need a stander how to survive the
University continues to come back as a
[ __ ] belt there's a wish I've had it
I enjoyed business 101 hungry the first
business one just cuz I think those
stories are always like at the time not
funny at all I loved it when things
going wrong and not funny at all
afterwards hilarious true life hacks 107
was very good as well I remember no I do
talk about some life hacks like Fox 107
was where we really went off I think
it's
an hour and 40 as I can really want to
prop the [ __ ] 1 we're done with
our questions and let's build on about
God or the second one here how to 1 how
to start improving the value of your in
a circle and stepping away from negative
/ passive people be friends with people
that want the best for you
John pits and all over again just in
terms of how you do that someone else's
question in the day about like how do
you improve your network and I just said
for me it's always be in the gym I think
rather like met the most interesting
people like if you want to meet
interesting people go to interesting
places not I say the gym is an
interesting place but like you can say
the furnisher as long as you're not
going to like a class and exercise for
less whatever like if you go to
something that like you're interested in
a business you'll probably find someone
who's interested in same thing they're
probably also interested in other
self-development things and so so I
think that you'll find those people yeah
if you go to the Hangout of the interest
for that thing and you're more likely to
find a higher quality people within that
if you've joined something that's behind
a paywall so if you join a mentorship or
a gym or something that's exclusive but
it's for people that because they will
put their money where their mouth is and
they've all like decided to enter into a
a network here to something to really
take things faster George McGill when
does Johnny plan on using snapshots
there you go sorry George that's a good
suggestion you wasn't looking into
social commando what your thoughts on
insta removing the follower and like
numbers I don't like the idea of
follower because I think that it is a an
indicator of credibility that they're
trying the removal of likes I think
there's no like boundary like I saw
earlier they can't comment surely cuz
then you can't comment as and you can't
see the number of comments
okay take out the money you can't scenic
here you can't see the engagement
basically on post someone said well
that's interesting wonder why they're
doing that in influence of stuff and
young people being obsessed with it this
is a narrative like yeah it's an
interesting experiment
like I think it's affected a lot of
influences negatively well that'sthat's
that credibility right that credibility
it's his currency isn't you exactly
Yusuf made a big career u-turn how did
he make that big decision and implement
it I think we discussed this in business
principles 102 definitely worth
listening back to yeah you just said
[ __ ] you I was sick it was yeah it was
pain avoidance rather than some kind of
noble motivation - yeah you're all
successful professionals
these are all stretchy very
professionals so you are all sexual
professionals and within fitness
nutrition meal prep and with ok
nutrition meal prep hacks and tips
slow-cooker hold on what's the question
I'm not sure about the first bit just
nutrition slash meal prep hacks and says
drop it don't drop it slow cooker yeah
for me removing gluten removing like big
sources of gluten and dairy has helped
like I can't believe you just said that
question it used to be a lot of posture
than you I've just switched it to
different starchy carbs right did you go
like um Violet Beauregarde in Willy
Wonka no just a little bit on bloopers
after all you don't think that but I
mean I would like to and I remember that
actually I'm not celiac and it's fine we
all occasionally have epically failed
slash down days such get pissed off how
do you deal them she ingested
change of temperature so move so here's
an interesting thing what we wanted to
chat about this ages ago you said I get
the same 0 1 4 mentality chef in
training a means of flow but crisscross
effect you definitely do and it's I
think it's because you get there is a
debtor definitely
and you're immediately in a bad mood and
you immediately forgotten what you're
worrying about before yeah so that's
what made me go back to like just get up
that go for a run
move do something change your
temperature cold shower hot shower
coffee
the madman listened to bad teeth so yeah
the commonality there is get out of your
head into your body yeah and then yeah I
mean I said that quote is I got a better
mindset reset from training than I do
from a night's sleep yeah and that's
true my add more I wonder whether this
has actually been made worse by my
meditation practice the fact that my
emotions are a little bit more
transparent to me now and concentration
clarity and equanimity I'm trying to
hold them with more of that which
actually means that they're more
visceral and they're more of the
forefront of everything but yet just go
train I have like real depressive
episodes which I haven't had
thankfully I haven't had really that
much recently so when it's those ones
it's a there's not really much of a
solution like when it's a proper car to
get out of bed day try and get out of
bed try and go for a little walk
I did a tweet not long ago that said
almost all of the problems in my life
can be fixed by a ten-minute walk a good
night's sleep a glass of water or a wank
all at once actually it got a follow-up
for that sort of stuff
is Paul Mott there's a he's was
diagnosed with bipolar he said yeah what
I'd like professional help but now like
myself manages and he has a lot of stuff
about state change in his bank his quote
is like the state where attention where
attention goes energy flows so there's a
lot of stuff about like focusing on you
feel that way so it's like right what's
a win I've had today where I'm just
gonna focus on I'm trying to put all my
energy that this thing or you know he
like Kosan gets in his car and plays
music really loud and goes for a drive
yeah you know you can immediately think
like probably what do you think what do
you think is the biggest factor in
sticking to your goals and avoiding
getting dissed
rekted that's that's from Jake you need
to know what your goals are I'm terrible
I've never done proper genuine long-term
planning for girls ever I just think you
can but I've never done it I've never
even done any sort of more like
moderately formalized process like the
closest I've come its future authoring
from John piece and then I did half of
the course so I just sticking to your
goals requires you to have goals and
unless you go through a process of
working out what it is that you want and
then deciding how you even begin to move
towards that you just like 90 percent of
people will say I don't achieve I
haven't achieved my goals and you say
okay what are your goals and they won't
have an answer so this is the quote that
Chris often quotes which is he who has
the right Y can bear almost any heart
from Nietzsche and like yeah if you know
what the high-level thing that you're
aiming for is then putting those jigsaw
pieces into place becomes much more
effortless because it's all with a
greater purpose in mind the thing was if
you'd wake up he's falling in our our
the thing that made me feel like a prick
was the quote from James Smith James
Smith James cliff where he's like or
someone who rephrased it whereas like
everyone on the start line of the
hundred meters Olympics has the goal to
win the hundred meters but one of them
wins than the only the difference is not
the goal the differences that's the
process you spend all this time like
setting these goals in your life you
know I actually like Bill Gates has got
gold like probably similar business
goals that grow his business but he
really he really achieves it not a licen
has a great rebuttal to that that
systems without goals are pointless
systems so that the system have to have
a be attached to something i sorry agree
with that yeah it's really good really
nice compliment to that the ever
accepting nature of the CrossFit
community where does it come from
or is the CrossFit member-based the most
affluent consumer
as consumers on earth probably there
that so CrossFit's quite an elitist like
quiet especially in the UK it's pretty
privileged like very white very
middle-class at least in our gym and
wearing that you know what in the thick
thick of the New Castle 70 castles Nazis
are hardly hardly in that Taftville
temple towers carpet yeah it is indeed
yeah it's sir now is it good that is a
good point I think one of the other
things is that across its branded itself
as it looks cool like if you dress like
a powerlifter outside of the gym people
walk on the other side of the street T
if you dress like a cross fair outside
of the gym you look like someone that
does Fitness mhm mhm
I mean yeah it's a commercially
acceptable face of power lifting
strength sports endurance like you don't
have to wear tights you'd have to wear a
wetsuit you don't have to wear like
weird heavy-metal t-shirts and like a
beard and it's it's very young Virginie
felt extremely welcomed and I didn't
expect that I thought I'd get like who's
this guy you you know big 300 kilo
deadlift like that's Sherman yeah but
it's been the opposite of that it's been
you know like coaches like taking extra
time to explain something like I can't
do a toast about like how bad is that
but explaining it to me but the I think
for me it's the it's the branding
probably like they make it look
aspirational you don't watch you don't
even watch a limp ik lifting on TV it's
probably that like a limpet lifting a
strongman
not many people sit and watch like Brian
Shaw a Christmas and thankfully I Brian
Shaw oh I like my Bradshaw was like I
didn't they he's gonna have a bar back
where he watched like the CrossFit
documentaries and you think like rich
Froning just look badass like you can do
all this stuff he looks good healthy
healthy yeah
good like rounded family like yeah are
you here at this story's about Eddie
Hall like where he was at when you're
ready now
is proper - ready but when he was at the
peak of his career it was like my it was
it was pretty a demented with another
six months if marriage would have been
[ __ ] her heart out because what was
[ __ ] yeah filly for drama have you
ever seen it you've got some new ones on
the second story yeah yeah what would be
your ultimate life Huck you already
covered oh yeah um
spike oh yeah she trans athletes be
allowed to compete as the gender they
identify us so I really like Joe Rogan's
perspective on this I don't know which
is the with with combat sports
particularly we need to be very careful
about is is it progressive to allow
someone who has been physiologically a
man for thirty years and transitioned
very recently to beat up a woman when
there is an unfair combat advantage in
terms of reflexes total muscle mass
about a hundred on this idea that it's
someone's biological capability to
influenced by the gender they were or
like the sex they were other than I will
not be saying it wrong but you know what
I mean yeah like that you know if you if
you take gender out of it and you say
you have two humans mm-hmm
competing in the combat sport one of
them's had 30 years of testosterone and
then stop the testosterone and that's
influenced their physiology in such a
way that they have an unfair advantage
is not fair from a sporting perspective
and I think you've got to really
separate the socio-cultural issues of of
gender and gender politics from just the
pure sporting judgement or just hormones
yeah like hormones are one of the most
important things in competitive sport
was my [ __ ] how ignorant like dick
pound is the head of wallet or like a
baby was like dick pound his sack that
he is all he's thinking about is on what
are we allowing people to have in their
bodies and not having their bodies and
then you take as you say like someone
who's had 30 years of high levels of
testosterone and then they decide to
compete with women's you've got two
things running up against each other
which is one someone's right to express
the gender identity that they feel they
should express in a sport that they love
and the other is sporting flowers yeah
because even before all of the safety
things it's like 100-meter sprint the I
think the evening I think it might be
golf or tennis it's in tennis like the
thousandth man in the world would be
Serena Williams apparently right like
it's but they play I don't know where
this is the same thing but they play
like a different volume of tennis and
they male and female tennis players it's
totally different tactic I think but
even if you just look at the raw data
it's like look at the hundred me at
times of the men and the women let's say
you allow one of those men to assign
themselves as a woman and compete when
the women with the female Olympics he's
that fair on the female athletes who
were competing last year well there's a
weightlifter one that transition Laurel
a bird Lord was that like clean jokes
1:30 in the like top weight category
which for a man is it
Prasanna jokes high higher than higher
than normal testosterone was it was that
was that that thing I was like I thought
it was someone who I know the person
called Laurel that was one of the big
weight lifting things so I had a fairly
lengthy discussion with zubi about this
he was a guy who tweeted saying people
say there's no biological difference
between men and women watch me smash the
world women's deadlift record psi
identified his woman side by did while
doing this don't be a bigger
and he pulled 230 sumo and that is four
kilos under is max but 10 kilos over the
woman's in that way category and then
correct weight category the question
that I haven't actually got around to
speaking about spoke to Andrew Doyle
about this as well is the other side of
the debate which is what do you do as a
trance a flee like if you're a man his
transition to be a woman and you're a
boxer and you want a box who the [ __ ]
you box I'm here Ben told me was was
talking about this up with someone
saying that like we just maybe need to
use a different definition of
male-female like I don't know whether
it's basing on chromosomes or basing on
something something that's not the way
that we currently define the problem is
this that there's a lack of clarity
between what male as xx XY definition
with tighten with hormone profile and
gender expression or gender identity is
and then you're trying to fit these
square pegs into round holes that work
for sport yeah and this is where the
difficulty lies and 50% of the
difficulty of when people are having
these discussions is that people play
linguistic tricks and they go right well
you've said woman do not mean woman I
wanna have a discussion of a different
thing navigate like you try talking
about it it's a difficult thing to get
missing the right things and express it
the right way even more different a lot
of things wants to get offended though
there's no waiting for you to us they've
got you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] trans folk especially when
they have an opinion and if you express
an opinion that isn't their opinion
you're immediately unfair and oh maybe I
just think is something different to you
um so yeah that's that's definitely one
of the things but yet the question of it
like do you then you obviously would be
fairly prejudice to segregate trans
across and say right okay here's a male
to female and a female to male and can't
agree that you can only go I mean that's
gonna be so whittled down that it's it's
gonna be a terrible sport to watch or be
involved in because you never gonna find
someone who's with a similar
capacity to you but it's fraught to try
and continue to fit these things into
the existing setups because the house to
be parameters for sport like it isn't
sport if it's just a me can do whatever
the [ __ ] they want because they're not
it's unfair and I wade into the 105's at
one but I'm gonna teach my identify is
105 yeah I can I identify as a 74 that
would help me immensely so it's like
there is a parameter that is set and
soaked it's a number on the scale and
Wilkes and you know the hundred meter
time all these things are data points
that cannot be hockey with because this
is this is still a parameter which
affects the fairness of the game that is
being played but because there's an
emotional aspect of it it gets very
tense very quickly
it's the bench Pierrot question right
why aren't you 60 yeah why have you six
it's yeah well because I'm I'm not yeah
yeah is it 20 listen he's like are you a
tree no why not cuz you're not a tree
okay well we're getting somewhere
yeah the terrible impression Bishop the
Shapiro mama is like are you 60 why
aren't you 60 and the girl says well
because there's there's there's not
there's there's a bit of a difference
between what I am now and being 60 and
he says yes there is but there is a much
bigger difference between you being a
woman and you being a man and the
problem with this is that because of how
militant some active voices have been on
the left on this issue what you will do
is you will like just put in like in
volleyball it's like that little setup
is for the spike yeah and then someone
like some [ __ ] like Peterson or
Harris or Shapiro he's gonna come in and
they're gonna eviscerate someone and
make sure they're silly
Wow and then and then what's gonna
happen is they're gonna be accused of
being insensitive which perhaps they've
delivered it in a sensitive way yes and
then it's like I'm not and they go back
and then it creates his game attacks
well yeah like it and I think like this
is why I think like I mean I'm a
clinician I'm a scientist
not interested in really in the gender
politics and it's like okay so if we
want to if it's a real questions was
actually interested in how do we judge
sports let it's light right what is the
fundamental premise that we are saying
here we're saying we have two divisions
men men and women first of all should we
have two divisions split up like that
that's the first question the next one
is is there a objective difference
between men and women is there a
biological difference and that point
alone is still being debated leather
still people that believe that there is
no no biological difference between men
and women then just the way that the
socializes children said so then you're
like okay well I mean that's that's fine
to believe if you if you want to believe
that on your own but then do you have
any problem taking testosterone for 30
years or do you have any problem like
competing in a way if you access Michael
I okay well should we allow drugs and
sports like the Lance Armstrong was what
did what what he was doing is that okay
well it's fine because it wouldn't make
a difference having testosterone or not
because it's it doesn't there's no so I
think because of the fundamental premise
isn't really clearly fleshed out then it
means you can't move any further forward
because it's like that still have like
calories in calories out is by gravity
and if you're saying you don't believe
in gravity than I don't know interesting
like getting in your plane whatever I've
butchered it but you know there are
fundamental things that have to be
alright fine
gravity exists its Blau let's talk about
be together even with all of those
things right and I said this 200 or anti
zoobi as I this whole trans athletes in
sports thing is a [ __ ] very highly
charged minefield I'm gonna I'm
incredibly glad that I don't need to try
and litigator like can you imagine if
you're the man who has to work out
whether or not transitioning athletes it
should be dick pond dick pound he'll be
up there dick you'll be on the ground is
what I've decided housing a difficult
job made a kind of adjacent question to
this toxic masculinity in quotation
marks is from Luke toxic masculinity
who's to blame more for its creation
men or women
so what what is toxic masculinity
doesn't exist as far as I'm concerned
yeah I'm not I'm not sure on tyranny but
toxic masculinity is the over battle
over expression of typically masculine
traits to a tyrannical or oppressive
level okay some mansplaining man
spreading everything lanolin it
Manchester manual yeah
Stephen manual Stephen manual as far as
I'd like to know his opinion on this as
far as I'm concerned there's no such
thing as toxic masculinity it's just
people naming things it's just people
naming character traits you have people
that are girly girly guys and masculine
guys toxic masculinity to me is just the
same as toxic femininity like do you
think like you know the generations
prior to us like you know generation
that dealt with like World War two I
just think maybe I'm wrong but I imagine
if you presented them as sort of things
and being argued about now mmm they just
be upset there's a clip of George of
George from mental models 1 or 2 saying
something like that it's like something
about being on the frontline in World
War two and then they're like oh my a
sticker like I can't deal acts I don't
identify as a soldier on the other side
on the other side of that question it's
no use to any of us to judge the life
that we have now with the lens that we
would have used 100 years ago like I'm
not saying I don't know why I'm [ __ ]
bothered about getting cancer at least I
didn't buy it died of the bubonic plague
like yeah I need to I need to refine the
fidelity of my view for what criteria I
need my life and the life of those
around me to be a as time progresses and
as life gets better like yes we are no
longer a world war therefore I can start
to look at things like what our
attention device is doing to my brain as
long as it's not I feel like some of
these things feel very much like they're
making a problem they're like if you sow
toxin so gentle but yeah like so being
in a landing craft we arrived about to
arrive on I know
beaches that is for no wood argument
that is a problem you're about to
experience a serious play and and but
you know in the same way cancer is a
problem like you can't argue that
because cancer isn't it we've got a
plague that it's not as bad you know
it's a cellar problem to deal with for
like if you are everything in your life
is is alright but you decide that
actually toxic masculinity really
offends you you say well it does it does
it have to or are you choosing for it to
be the case like if people lie to
themselves so effectively I think a lot
of people would struggle to answer that
think'll and especially if you then add
in availability bias and echo chambers
and yeah if all you mates agree with you
yeah then you can create yourself to
believe anything that you want right
suppose we all have to have something to
focus on think about so why not make it
toxic masking
why don't we all should get really upset
about it about toxic masculinity and
then there's a militia who we can do
which we can join and they are humble
and grateful and they're independent
let's be stopped there's two points here
from my housemate who's upstairs number
one best way to go about getting on the
property ladder or investing in property
thing this will be useful to lop even me
let's try and do a really quick version
of this build up 35 grand build up 35
grand purchase a property which has at
least two bedrooms ideally three if you
can let the other two that's it
I've invest in REITs was I'm a real
estate investment trust are they
available Nika yeah so it's an
investment vehicle that basically allows
you to get some of the game you probably
know better than I do
allows you to get some of the game off
property without actually owning
property yeah it's like a aggregate of a
property portfolio that you get to buy
in like a certain amount into and
because you don't then the discrete sums
of 35 gram but you know the deposit per
thing you can can get exposure to the
return of the properties that the REIT
is investing in without having to go all
the JV you should say yeah this isn't
financial advice this is not financial
advice yeah it's just saying there is
just there is legal this is what we are
aware of
what we might do maybe part to saps
advice to zero jealousy Seth Seth say
he's called you Seth but I've I've
changed it cuz go means Seth steps
advice to zero jealousy how much are
calling yourself a set you said well
like Samuel fine so it was it was quite
simple I just well something a rock good
two hours and it was something that at
the time for me was very pertinent as a
front of my consciousness and I think
when something is at the forefront you
if you dive into it
you realize it's like a bubble it's it's
looks like it's really big and
intimidating and overbearing and you
just penetrate to the center of it and
then it'll burst and you realize there's
no pain as hashed hurt anymore and the
triggers that would normally have sat
that off just aren't there they don't
exist anymore so did you have any
suggestions of places for people to to
learn like stop and journey maybe yeah I
listen Tim Lind
where did you go yeah it was in Finland
I remember so there's a few resources to
start with but I enough I've not read
this but I this might be a more
accessible one is a book called radical
acceptance because I think the the
methods that I use kind of twisted into
each other there's there's too much to
trace back from but literally just
sitting and except like diving into the
story all of the physical sensations all
of the the thoughts and beliefs around
it and just keep diving into it until it
you're fully comfortable with it because
what you're probably doing is holding it
away in some capacity and if that
approach doesn't work then the Byron
Katie method that Johnny mentioned is
very effective for interpersonal griefs
just anything happens anything basically
anything in your life you can use that
process for ask for questions and flat
tire
Gary Webber is a good guys to look into
for this stuff because he did this with
just everything in his life
yeah and who did he like took Baron ke
and the desert owner yoga meditation all
211 didn't he doesn't yeah and he's JT's
functionally changed his brain and it's
been replicated on MRIs like he's just
got a permanent shift in the way that
his brain you watch the daniel ingram
interview with you surf daniel
increments on skype the youtuber didn't
just tell just watch the way that he
expresses himself which is his line
about him totally like especially i use
a hundred percent can you look into that
cameron do it for me he's a hundred
percent present completely emotionally
neutral happy it's like his tinge of
this is fun but if it changed it
wouldn't matter
yeah yeah watch the interview with
Daniel Ingram great we couldn't get Gary
Weber on the podcast he's new he
declined last one where did the
inspiration to do the podcast come from
from Sean Jay I did Chris fit on the
program fitness podcast what like three
years ago to now three years ago time
ago in our office really enjoyed the
process loved having discussions decided
I wanted to do it more what was his
first episode this it wasn't stoom on
growing their own then life hacks 101
and one or two and number two on three
when I started CrossFit I went back and
listened to the episodes of Jordan and I
got four and Tim yeah yeah it's
interesting time ago those ones but yeah
thank you very much for tuning in 100
episodes deep hope you enjoyed q Chris
thank you for doing 100 episodes of
modern mr. great questions great oh
really good question we'll do another
Q&A if you want any comments that you
have obviously leave them below if
you're on youtube if not if you're on
itunes or wherever else leave us five
stars it does make me very happy and it
helps with the show's rating what we've
got coming up bloody hell we've got
Jesse Ferguson the girl that owns and
Miami dot VIP which is a really
interesting way that girls have
decentralized the ability to
from their nudes who thought that was
going to be a thing 2019 we're going to
do more business principles more
lifehacks will be coming and [ __ ] knows
we've got another hundred episodes to
get to before we have to think about
something cool to do for episode 200 I
think by like episode 300 keywords are
just gonna be links to other podcasts
doesn't matter what anyone asks us it'll
just be episode 13 2924 and we'll just
have all that in fact that should be the
mission to be absolutely index so if you
name index your knowledge into podcasts
so effectively no human can come up with
a question that hasn't already been
answered and then as well and someone
left it like you know the IBM Watson I
make a new one of them to ask us a
question that's nice it's a great new
prime numbers or they're coin miner to
find the next possible question yeah
well then we'll just making your podcast
and then we're all done
don't forget follow the guys from
program fitness they do post some
interesting stuff and have a fantastic
podcast like share subscribe thank you
very much indeed
100 episodes we did it baby yes okay bye
then your mother
[Music]
you